all right
hello everybody
and thank you all for taking time out of
what's got to be an incredibly busy day
to join us for this webinar
my name is karen white and i'm on the
product team here at khan academy
i'm also the mother of two girls ages 12
and 17
both of whom have been out of school
since last friday one with the distance
learning plan and one with no plan at
all so we are definitely winging it here
in san jose california while we shelter
in place i'm sure many of you are as
well
with me today we have dan chu from our
marketing team you can see him if you go
to the next slide uh see him pictured
there with his uh nieces and nephews
and we have sophie turnbull uh in that
picture with the helicopter she's going
to be talking to those of you with
little ones about how to get started on
our con kids app which is designed as a
mobile app for kids two through seven
i want to thank our friends at bank of
america for generously supporting our
ability to bring school closures
resources to you at this time
and finally before we dive in i just
want to mention that this session will
be recorded and it'll be sent out by
email
soon after we finish the session also
uploaded to youtube for easy access so
if you need to step away if you miss
parts don't worry about it it will be
available to you to review and to share
with your friends and family
so with that
today we're going to help you and your
child get started on khan academy
if you are a teacher we are not going to
be going to the teacher experience in
this webinar but we're going to send
these slides out and that link on the
right over there that says watch this
webinar that will take you to a teacher
webinar we recorded earlier uh this week
it's fantastic and it'll give you
everything you need to get started there
we're also not going to be doing a
step-by-step walkthrough of the setup
but in a couple slides you're going to
see our quick start guides that actually
will do that for you quite well
so
a little bit more about khan academy
first of all
this came up in a number of questions
from the pre-webinar survey
khan academy is free
we are a non-profit organization and all
of our instruction and practice is
always free to learners and parents and
their teachers
khan academy is a trusted source you can
trust us because we've been doing this
for a long time for more than 10 years
with millions of users around the world
all of our math courses are common core
aligned and our other non-ap math
courses include both common core
material and additional content
our ap math courses are aligned to the
ap standards and as i mentioned we
served
even before
the school closure started we were
serving well over 10 million learners
around the globe every month
and finally khan academy is flexible the
khan academy main app which is what i'm
going to be talking to you about is
available on desktop web ios or android
anytime anywhere translated into over 40
languages sophie's going to talk to you
later on about the con kids app which is
a mobile app only but khan academy the
main khan academy we're going to be
talking about for the next 10 minutes or
so is available on desktop as well
so now let's get into what it really
means to learn on khan academy and in
our pre-webinar survey the most common
question we got and thanks to everyone
who took the time to to fill it out the
the most question caution question the
most common question we got was how do i
figure out what my child should be
learning it's a great question because
if you're like me you might not know
exactly what your kids were up to right
before the school closure started and
you're certainly not used to teaching it
right i've been
a mother to my younger daughter for 12
years and i've been her teacher for
about 12 hours so
i uh you know would say the first thing
to do is pet yourself on the back for
trying to pull this off during a time
that has a lot of other stressors in
play as well
so with that preamble here are a few
tips to
getting started
first things first look at your child's
homework and their test books
if you have access to a parent or
student portal
through your school you might be able to
log in and see what assignments your
teachers your your child's teachers have
lined up
before school let out that will give you
some clues as to where to start their
learning path
if you don't have that that's okay
you can select a course on khan academy
based on your child's age and grade and
you can navigate your way through that
any number of ways you can start with
their very first lesson
we're going to talk in a few minutes
about how to start with a course
challenge to identify learning gaps
quickly
or you can let your child choose where
to start and even if your child chooses
something that kind of feels easy to you
that's okay
those early math skills are foundational
to more advanced math
and
you know it's not necessarily a bad
thing to have your child review that
material and gain confidence and really
just keep the brain training going while
we're in this really unusual time
um finally for high school students who
are enrolled in ap or are studying for
the sats we have
most pop the most popular ap courses on
khan academy and we also have our
official sat prep i can vouch for that
as a parent of a senior
um it is uh incredibly valuable my
daughter used it as her sole way to
prepare for the sat
and was really really happy with her
results
so overall if i had to give you one
mantra to remember it's this
some learning is better than no learning
don't let perfect be the enemy of good
there's all sorts of things that are
being demanded of you right now and just
you know get started it's very easy to
course correct to change your learning
path and make adjustments as you go with
khan academy
so
next up i want to share those quick
start guides i was mentioning
these links again this will be provided
to you after the webinar there are three
different guides here two for khan
academy and one for khan academy kids um
just for a little bit of context on why
we have different guides for younger and
older children on khan academy it
basically comes down to the fact that
there are some regulatory requirements
around setting up accounts for younger
kids
that require your approval and so what
we wanted to do is give you the absolute
fastest most efficient way to get
started based on your child's situation
and these guides are customized for the
fastest path through to get your child
learning and then to get you set up as a
parent
so
lots of support in there in those guides
what i'm going to do now is jump into
what happens once you're signed up and
this is what you're going to see first
you're going to be
offered the opportunity to personalize
your child's learning
selecting the grade level and seeing
what courses we recommend
now regardless of our suggestion your
child can choose any course on khan
academy so if you have a child who's
really
into math and he's generally performing
above grade level
and loves a challenge you can choose any
course that's right for that child same
the other way if you have someone
struggling don't feel bound to the grade
level suggestions
and
after you've done that
so you've selected a course you can
select more than one
you can always go back and add um this
is what your child's experience is going
to look like the courses will show up on
the home page whenever they log in
and you'll see the khan academy is
designed to give your child a lot of
agency in terms of where they're going
to go to do their next task and that can
be great if you've got a child who's
engaged and motivated
let them roam around let them take these
things in the order that that sparks
their interest and energy
it can also be a little challenging and
overwhelming if you've got a younger
child to have so many choices so one of
the things we like to do when we're in
the classroom with young children is say
follow the blue button you can see there
that red arrow is pointing at a blue
start button
that's pretty much always going to be a
good call it will essentially take the
child um linearly through the course
starting with the most basic skills and
advancing from there so
always an option if you want to give
your child
a little bit more of a sense of where to
go next
so once you've done that
if you were to click into any one of
those
units
those
then turn into lessons
that include
instruction
practice and assessments
uh if you look at where those arrows are
you can see the practice exercises on
the right
and the instructional resources on the
left
so if your child is practicing and is
finding that the material is a little
bit challenging but not so challenging
that they want to move to a different
level
they're likely to find an article or a
video or a series of them right next to
that practice content that can support
them
as they're practicing and reinforce
those skills
and then the other thing i want to
mention is this course challenge so
every most of our math courses are going
to have this challenge
um and it's a great way to accelerate
the process of getting your child to
that learning edge that place where
they're struggling a little bit in a
productive way but not so much that they
get discouraged
and the way to do this is you scroll to
the bottom of the course page and you'll
see this button that says
start course challenge
um you know these do take a little bit
of time so you want to leave 30 or 45
minutes for the child to get through
that but what you're going to come out
of it with is a sense of the skills that
they're really comfortable with
and the skills where they might need
some more practice
especially given where we are in the
school year this is a pretty good option
for you because there's going to be a
lot of content that feels familiar
um in most cases so starting at the
beginning may not be what you need to do
the one
caveat i'll say is at least if you've
got a child who uh is generally in the
mode of performing hi being high
performer um the course challenge can
feel a little bit
like a test that they didn't get to
study for
uh i know from my daughter when i put
this in front of her she's she was still
in that mindset of i have to get an a
but really what the course challenge is
for is identifying where she needs to
practice so i needed to really kind of
encourage her and coax her along to make
her comfortable with the idea that this
wasn't a test she didn't need to get an
a and this was really about finding the
best ways for her to spend time on khan
academy
so
when they're practicing we've really
designed khan academy to be a delightful
learning experience we celebrate when
they've leveled up they'll see confetti
there are bells um when you're on a roll
you'll you'll get a nice
surprise every time you um you answer a
question right and there are videos and
hints to get in the moment support as
you go
we really try with khan academy to
celebrate grit and perseverance not just
leveling up because that's what having a
growth mindset is all about
so now i'm going to very briefly talk
about the parent tools that you can
access as part of your parent account
and the main thing you're going to do
when you're logged in as a parent is
look at your child's progress
this report is essentially like being in
the room with your child looking over
their shoulder seeing what they're
working on except without the looking
over their shoulder part so it's almost
like an audit trail that shows you every
exercise how much time they spent on it
and how they did and there's really
three values i think that are going to
be helpful to you as you're coaching
your child or thinking about how to
motivate um their work
there are two numbers you'll see in
there the two numbers both say three in
this particular case one is the time
spent on exercises which is the real
practice of applying the skills
and the other is the total learning time
on khan academy which includes things
like watching videos or reading articles
you're looking for in general a mix of
those things not just uh in not just the
instruction but also the
practice and then the third thing you're
going to see are those little arrows you
can see a little green one there on the
screen
that's going to tell you when a skill is
leveling up or down and what we
essentially mean by that is your child
is in if the skill is going up it means
they're making progress towards mastery
of that skill and if mastery sounds like
a
a fancy term what it really means is
this child is getting so good at the
skill that they could probably explain
it to somebody else they could almost
teach it
there also are going to be
red arrows if the child is struggling
and maybe going down the level on a
skill and those are your opportunities
to say hey let's lean in a little bit
here maybe review some videos and um and
then
support them with instruction
so this is all a good segue into
the last few minutes i'm going to spend
on khan academy before turning it over
to sophie
and
it's really about how do we motivate and
structure the students day
let's face it
it's hard there's a lot competing for
your child's attention right now let
alone your own
and um
you know just be kind to yourselves
but i always like to remind myself that
at the end of the day yes i want my kids
to be learning but the most important
thing is we're all going to be stuck in
this house a lot together so we had
better get along
so in terms of setting uh goals it's
great to
include your children in the process
they're going to be more invested if you
do it that way
and take it one day at a time if the
goals you set for your first day
don't turn out to be particularly
realistic given your situation
stay flexible
let yourself
give yourself some slack we're all in
uncharted territory right now
and then recognize milestones we always
like to celebrate both the progress and
the effort so when you look at those
numbers around time that's one of the
ways you can congratulate your child for
making the effort
and then look for those level ups as an
indication that your child is making
progress
all right one last thing i think some of
you probably have seen we have
posted online a number of templates for
daily schedules that can help you just
get a little bit more of that structure
that helps your child be calm creates a
sense of predictability and gives you
some room to maneuver because you have a
sense of how your day is going to go
so feel free to click through on those
when you get the materials and hope
that they are helpful to you as they
have been to me in terms of giving your
children some some structure and order
in what is kind of a chaotic time
and with that i will turn it over to you
sophie
hi everyone i'm sophie from khan academy
kids and tonight i'm really excited to
walk you through the basics on getting
set up how to learn at home with your
kids on khan academy kids
khan academy kids is made by khan
academy it's a mobile app that is
separate to the khan academy app or the
khan academy desktop experience and it's
designed especially for children ages 2
through 7.
it's available on your mobile be it and
apple ios or android as well as touch
screen chromebooks
and you can find it in the app store
that you use
so what we're going to do right now is
quickly watch a demo of how to get set
up on khan academy kids in about three
minutes
so the first thing you want to do is go
to your app store and download khan
academy kids
once you've done that you can open our
app
and you'll be greeted by our fun
character khan
you'll be taken to a sign up screen
click sign up and enter your email
we use this email to create your account
and we're going to ask you to verify it
so once you've entered it and clicked
next you'll receive an email in your
email inbox
and you want to click the verify email
button
in that email and then you're set to go
back into the app and start creating
accounts for your kids
click next here
and here you are
first we're going to add the name of our
first child kim
kim is six and we'll select an avatar
for kim
a dolphin ready to start learning now
but we'll quickly show you how to create
a profile for another child if you swipe
up into the parents section you'll see
kim's account there tap the new button
swipe up and enter the name of
the next child oscar
oscar is actually older he's seven and
he is going to be a tiger
and now we have two children's profiles
kim
and oscar we're going to start learning
with kim so we tap kim
and if we press the play button here
we'll be in our personalized learning
path it'll serve up age appropriate
activities for your child like this one
and together they have five toy
dinosaurs
if you wanted to do self-serve you could
click in the top left corner on the
library icon
then you can scroll through all of our
activities books videos
our reading our logic social emotional
learning and you can pick out what your
child works on
we've partnered with national geographic
and bellwether media to offer a range of
characters and stories and formats to
keep your child busy and there's always
the offline functionality that suitcase
under the word library
we can't wait for you to discover
everything there is to do on khan
academy kids
so now you should be ready to get
started learning and i want to run
through a few of the questions that
we've been getting from parents learning
at home with their kids
i mentioned the home screen if you press
that big green play button on the home
page you'll go into the personalized
learning path and if you press the top
left library icon you'll go into the
library well what's the difference
between those two
the personalized learning path is an
automatic playlist of
all of our activities math and reading
social emotional learning books and
videos and they get served up to your
child
to
meet them where they're at so they're
age appropriate and they're
automatically served up
the learning path might be a good idea
if you just can't be there to pick and
choose every activity that your child is
doing for a certain part of the day
the library is where you can self-serve
out of our catalog of activities it's
the blue the book icon in the top left
hand corner of the home screen
all of the activities are the same it's
just about how they're served up to you
do you want to pick and choose what your
child is doing from one activity to the
next or are you happy to let them work
their way through the personalized
learning path it's totally up to you
now i want to cover some quick tips for
learning at home with khan academy kids
all of karen's points about having a
daily schedule but being flexible and
motivating kids at home being terribly
difficult apply to two to seven year
olds
on the technical side though i want to
point out a couple of things
if you have to go offline i mentioned
the suitcase icon in the library tap
that all your child's progress will be
saved and uploaded when you go online
next
if you want to view progress go into
your child's library view and you'll see
green yellow and red check marks
indicating whether they've mastered
something they're still working on it or
they're yet to work on it
on the
content side there are a few things that
parents have pointed out to us parents
are loving using out the thousands of
books that we have to read to their
children we have books on everything
from animals to feeling frustrated so
have at it in the book section
parents have also been saying that
they're enjoying their healthy habits
throughout the app there are activities
on things like saying hello and making
friends even getting dressed in the
morning some of these habits that are so
important when we're cooped up inside
and so i encourage you to check those
out
in the logic tab
and then finally in the create tab your
child can do something
creative like drawing making a card for
a friend you can screenshot it and send
it on
and khan academy kids is really focused
on not just math and reading the core
academic subjects for two to seven year
olds but also making sure kids are
creative that they're interacting with
you that they're moving around getting
up and jumping and making zoo animal
noises uh and really developing their
whole selves
the last thing i want to mention is that
there are some places you can go for
more information so teachers should look
out for the teacher guide that is linked
in the quick start
handout that we are posting on this
webinar it has a whole lot about how you
might teach remotely with khan academy
kids
and if you have any questions about
getting started please email khan that's
k-h-a-n kids
khan academy org
and you should follow us on social media
if you're into that for daily activities
things like circle time and what to do
with your kids on khan academy kids
thanks so much
all right thank you sophie and karen hi
everyone it's dan here um i'd like to
for you all to do two steps before we
open it up to live questions um first if
you can all go out to the handout
section and grab the cheat sheet it
contains guidance through this entire
process
from finding the right content for your
kids to tracking their progress and
through creating structure and
motivation it also contains step-by-step
instructions on how to set up an account
and links to other parent resources so
feel free to download it and share with
other parents friends and families
and secondly if you have any questions
please add them to the question box
i'll be facilitating while karen and
sophie provide their expert answers
so let's go ahead and start with some
good questions that are coming in
and thank you everyone for submitting
so we have a question um karen for you
should my child have separate account
for me as a parent
yeah that's a great question and um
absolutely we would recommend that uh
you and your child have
uh separate accounts
first of all you have a set of uh
controls and settings that are
particular to the parent account but
there's a second reason that i want to
emphasize which is that you actually
may want to do some learning on khan
academy yourself
i have personally found that seventh
grade math feels like it was a really
really long time ago and so while your
child is learning in their own accounts
you can actually go in as a learner and
this is in the quick start guide and
practice yourself so you'll have your
own learning path if you have a separate
account from the one you set up for your
child
awesome thank you karen um this next one
i think is most appropriate for you
sophie is khan academy kids integrated
with the desktop khan academy
and can i see their progress from the
kids app on the desktop
so the short answer is no khan academy
kids is a mobile app and the progress
that your child makes on the khan
academy kids mobile app will not be
present on the khan academy desktop
experience we've designed it so that
it's touch screen and it's especially
for two to seven year olds and i think
in the future we look forward to linking
those two experiences but for now no
okay great thank you um here's a
question that either of you can answer
perhaps karen you you tackle it first
and um sophie can go next on this one so
we have a question from matthias tavares
apologies if i pronounce the name
incorrectly
so the question is how much should we
supervise our kids while they learn
yeah great question um
i guess my first response would be
how much can you i know at least for me
i am working during the day even though
i'm here at home so my ability to
supervise is fairly limited and i
imagine many of you are in the same
position and we have designed khan
academy so that
most children can
progress um independently um i like to
make myself available to be nearby but
if you're supervising because you want
to hold your child accountable that's
where that progress report becomes
really really valuable um your
your child cannot practice on khan
academy
without your seeing it and vice versa so
um that report will be your way of
staying connected with what your child
is learning even when you don't have the
ability to sit side by side
having said that if you do have the
ability and if your child welcomes it
it's a great it's a great chance to
really be part of their learning journey
yeah i would just quickly echo that uh
it's great for parents to be interacting
with khan academy kids while their child
is using it particularly in the library
mode but if you needed to step away for
a time and have your child learn
independently the personalized learning
path is really taking care of things
while you have to do that and you'll be
able to see a comprehensive view of
their progress when you go back into the
library
yeah keep in mind khan academy is used
in in schools all over the place
and
that's a situation where one teacher has
a group of 30 kids so it's definitely
designed for kids to be able to make
independent progress through a
combination of instruction and practice
paired together
without direct supervision
all right so i think we have time for
one more question
um karen this one's from heather uh will
be there be an answer key to help grade
if i'm a parent and not in a teacher
account
yeah great question so you will not get
an answer key uh but you actually won't
need to grade your child's practice
because they are getting real-time
feedback with every question so as the
questions are answered they will
immediately know whether that got the
question right or wrong they'll have
access to a hint
and they'll have access in many cases to
a rationale even if they do get it right
so there's really no need for an answer
key
all right so um thank you karen and
sophie for sharing your expertise with
our audience
and thank you to our audience for taking
the time out of your busy evening to be
with us we know there's so much going on
and we really appreciate you investing
your time into this session
um we know that we hit our limit in
terms of the number of people who wanted
to join the webinar so we apologize for
that um so for those of you who or may
know folks who were not able to get in
this will be this this will be recorded
this is recorded and we'll be posting it
live online and available to everyone
and so uh rest assured that this
information will be available to you
and secondly we also have quite a few
other resources available on our website
at khanacademy.org
there's currently a blue ribbon at the
very top we're adding new resources
every day and making changes quite
frequently so feel free to go there and
click through for more information
before we sign off please do us one more
favor and take the poll that pops up at
the very end of this webinar and let us
know two things first how could we make
future iterations of this session even
better for you all
and secondly what kind of sessions would
you like to see next so this was
obviously a relatively high level
session to get you all started but if
you want us to dive deeper into things
like motivation
specific courses like math or science
please let us know we're here to support
you this is the first of future webinars
that we want to create to be able to
support you through this time
so with that from all of us at khan
academy thank you again for joining us
and good night